who could replace dana white i've asked  this question from quite a few different  people  just curious to know what's your  thoughts on this and i don't think  i mean everybody  can sometimes say daniel cormier he said  daniel couldn't do my job but who do you  think could replace i don't think nobody  can replace dana white i don't think so  i mean i mean to do to be as good as  they know white was i think some someone  can come  and fill the old  maybe not be like dana white be better  at certain things that dana white maybe  sometimes i know it is not very  diplomatic so it could be  it could be more diplomatic but maybe to  to be a promoter to to be intense as as  unique as dana white is only one guy is  dana white  it doesn't mean his job cannot be taken  and he cannot be replaced i think  everybody can be  replaced  but  nobody everybody is unique and everybody  has a different unique personality